bei uns im studio ist jetzt marie agnes
strack zimmermann von der fdp die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
herzlich willkommen wir müssen damit
zunächst noch ein bisschen aufräumen und
klarheit schaffen friedrich merz sagt
die bundesregierung verzögert sie sagen
er sei schlecht informiert wie es also
der aktuelle stand in sachen
waffenlieferung friedrich merz ist nicht
nur
oppositionsführer sondern ist auch
stellvertretendes mitglied des
ausschusses und er sollte es besser
wissen der stand ist das in der tat wie
die panzerhaubitze 2000 schicken sieben
deutsche fünf niederländische und dass
die vorbereitet werden beziehungsweise
die die diese benutzen werden werden
gerade angewiesen das gerät und dann
gehen die in die ukraine da bitte ich um
verständnis dass ich hier kein datum
nennen das ist ja kein gerät was man in
die tasche steckt sondern was
entsprechend logistisch verlegt werden
wo es das zweite ist der gepard von dem
sie gerade sprachen die sind
ausgemustert gewesen standen also bei
der industrie auf dem hof müssen jetzt
wieder in die gänge kommen endlich das
mal so sagen darf es muss munition
gefunden werden ein system was es nicht
mehr gibt wird auch keine munition mehr
produziert das liegt in der natur der
sache ist nicht ganz einfach munition
wäre zum beispiel der schweiz die
wollten aber nicht liefern jetzt hat man
aber was gefunden und die sollen auch im
laufe der nächsten wochen geliefert wird
also friedrich merz weiss das ding
steckt man nicht in die tasche und
schrieb zwar über sondern sie müssen kam
fertig gemacht werden damit sie auch
kommunikativ funktionieren das hat
natürlich sicherheitsgründe weshalb sie
nicht sagen können wann da war es genau
geliefert wird aber jetzt geht es nur
noch mal zum verständnis und ein ganz
klares ja oder nein zur frage was bisher
schon gemacht wurde die entscheidung
liegt ja schon ein paar wochen jetzt
auch zurück ist schon etwas angekommen
oder nicht also bei dem großgerät noch
nicht ansonsten ist unglaublich viel
angekommen ich würde ihnen so gerne
darüber berichten die bundesregierung
ist so etwas zaghaft wir haben darum
gebeten als freie demokraten zu sagen
sagt es den menschen was wir geliefert
haben das ist nicht nur in
anführungszeichen humanitär das in
kleinwaffen und so weiter und so fort
damit man weiß was wir schon getan haben
sehr viel auch in einem sehr hohen
dreistelligen millionenbetrag und das
sollte man schon kommunizieren damit die
menschen nicht das gefühl haben die
deutschen regeln da hinterher dann haben
sie gerade das stichwort munition für
die gepaart panzer schon angesprochen
eigentlich ziemlich direkt nach ausbruch
des krieges die ukraine diese panzer ja
schon gefordert damals distanz macht
eigentlich gar keinen sinn weil wir
keine munition haben zwei monate später
entschließen wir uns ja doch wir können
wir eigentlich liefern aber die munition
gibt es immer noch nicht wie passt das
zusammen ja also die munition
herzustellen dauert natürlich sehr sehr
lange also was man der bundesregierung
wirklich vorwerfen muss dass sie so
lange gezögert haben wir sind jetzt fast
90 tage im krieg hätte man nach vier
wochen angefangen wer das alles schon
auf die hätte man das alles auf den weg
bringen können es sind bestände aus der
bundeswehr die bundeswehr ist natürlich
nicht wirklich begeistert weil man dinge
liefert oder angefordert wurden sind da
wurde auch lange über den marder
diskutiert ein entsprechender panzer
weil natürlich die bundeswehr nicht so
viel hat dass ihr das einfach abgeben
könnte wobei da hat sie eigentlich genug
und das sind eben immer so kommunikative
probleme man wartet zu lange und wie
gesagt das hätte alles schon beliefert
werden können aber der frage stellt sich
natürlich schon die frage man wartet
lange sie zögern dann entschließt man
etwas und dann passiert und wie trotzdem
erstmal nicht sie haben gestern dazu so
eine art sonderkoordinator sind wie neu
sie haben quasi gefordert da frage ich
mich das ist doch ich verstehe zwar dass
verschiedene positionen daran beteiligt
sind an diesen ganzen
entscheidungsprozessen aber das ist doch
federführend die aufgabe der
bundesverteidigungsministerium ist
federführend beim bundeskanzler er hat
das zur chefsache gemacht ist im
kanzleramt wird das koordiniert an der
seite des bundeskanzlers steht der
generalinspekteur der zorn der der erste
soldat ist aber herr zorn hat natürlich
die brille der bundeswehr auf der wird
nicht freiwillig alle depots öffnen auf
der anderen seite ist die industrie die
ist natürlich interessiert daran dass
ein oder andere was auf dem hof stand
jetzt auch raus zu geben und da ist die
ukraine die ukraine hat am anfang
wünsche geäußert nicht eine note
abgegeben also wo sie können jetzt nicht
ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht zu rufen ich
will das und hoffen das wird einer zum
hat schon einen juristischen weg den man
gehen muss und all diese bundeswehr
bundesregierung die industrie und auch
die ukraine müssen an einen tisch und er
muss einer ganz neutral sortieren was
ist der nächste schritt es ist
eigentlich relativ einfach man muss es
nur machen weil die letzten wochen wurde
auch sehr viel einander vorbei geredet
und wir haben einen krieg sie haben die
bilder gezeigt und das muss anders
organisiert seien an einen tisch sagen
manche seiten ja auch sollte man sich
auch mit putin setzen zumindest
diplomatischen kanäle aufrecht erhalten
wir wissen bundeskanzler scholz hat mit
putin vor kurzem noch mal sehr lange
telefoniert reicht denn das denn am ende
wird es doch ohnehin darauf hinauslaufen
dass man mit putin irgendeiner weise
sprechen und auch verhandeln muss also
mit putin zu verhandeln ist aussichtslos
die türkei hatte ja relativ zu beginn
des krieges zu nach dem überfall unter
russlands auf die ukraine um das korrekt
zu sagen gab es ein gesprächsformat in
der türkei das abgebrochen wurde weil
sinn und zweck dieses angriffs und das
sagt wladimir putin jetzt und das hat er
auch vor einem jahr sogar
verschriftlicht dass er gesagt hat die
ukraine gibt es nicht sie soll teil des
großen russischen reiches werden und er
akzeptiert die ukraine nicht als land
also auch die grenzen der ukraine nicht
und genau das ist das problem das heißt
wenn man etwas auslöschen will gibt es
keinen kompromiss und wir sollten uns
davon verabschieden dass es einen
möglichen kompromiss gibt diplomatisch
sozusagen hinter der front gibt es
kontakte das ist auch gut und das ist
auch hochrelevant ich sehe aber nicht
wladimir putin als verhandler neunter
mai jetzt gerade gewesen hatte er ja
sein seinem volk gesagt er kriegt wird
noch lange gehen hat sie eingeschworen
er könnte härter werden und man muss
wissen dass bis dato sehr sehr viele
russische soldaten junge männer gefallen
sind die aus zentralasien kam also aus
der russischen förderation
jetzt merken auch die russinnen und
russen in moskau und sankt petersburg
dass ihre söhne ums leben kommt das muss
putin erklären und er schwört sie eben
darauf ein in dem er behauptet russland
würde angegriffen das ist das narrativ
was er eben nach russland sendet und
letztendlich auch versucht der
westlichen welt weiß zu machen und wir
wissen dass er russland dass russland
die ukraine angegriffen hat und diese
sich sehr tapfer wehrt mit unserer
unterstützung der westlichen welt
hoffentlich auch diesen krieg nicht
verliert marianne strack zimmermann von
der fdp die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses bei uns heute
morgen im interview danke ich danke ihm